on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
tonight on piers morgan uncensored with
me jeremy kyle cyclists facing fines and
speed limits in a road law revolution
yippee
but will it simply drive an increase in
traffic
more criminals fewer investigations is
british policing facing a real emergency
and as inflation rockets past 10 and
surging supermarket prices give us the
chills at the teals how are we to
survive the food cost crunch
we know children with a cost of living
who they don't they evidently come to
school having not been fed
[Music]
[Music]
good evening my friends and a big big
welcome to piers morgan uncensored i'm
still jeremy carl and first tonight a
road riddle how do you get to use the
highways with no license no insurance
without paying any taxes with absolutely
no speed limit the answer is of course
as easy as riding a bike that's mibelle
i promise you one thing this is the only
time ever you'll see me doing this i get
irrationally angry about cyclists i mean
it we wrote this don't come near me i'm
a psychopath
but seriously nice what's not to loathe
there's the toy hoyes they dress up like
the tour de france from 15-minute pedal
to work he got the chain gangs usually
four of them riding side by side like
some massive peloton was us tax paying
motorists queue behind getting later and
later and more irate you've got the
sigourney weavers through the miss were
they like a shopping trolley with a
dodgy wheel and you're jeremy vines
whoever he is with more cameras than
kodak picking fights and running red
lights it's good news though it turns
out i'm not the only one who thinks
these two tired tyrants to run out of
road today the government announced
thank god it might just force cyclists
to buy insurance follow speed limits pay
fines for ignoring the laws of our road
so at last says me with one hand off the
wheel a common sense reform bringing
cycling into the 21st century oh no so
the cyclist reckless regulation we'll
end up with more people in their cars
we're going to debate that in a minute
but first my friends as i run out of
breath and look at why cyclists think
i've got this wrong i'm getting off now
you see i've got carpool tunnel syndrome
watch this
[Music]
hey
what
are you doing man
too busy doing that mate six points is
that one point five leaders overtaking
so you've been cool bye-bye now
brilliant right nick freeman the
transport lawyer so good he's known as
the loophole joins me now plus britain's
most militant cyclist dave sherry uh
let's start with you nick um you have
been urging the government to do this
for absolute ages it is chaos out there
i know cyclists won't like what i'm
gonna say right
but really isn't it time there was a
degree of responsibility
served on the cycling community nick
freeman
you're absolutely right jeremy um that
that they've avoided it for a long time
although it's the small minority
actually really against it but they're
very vociferous um there are many
cyclists have approached me and said
nick we actually agree with what you say
because it's going to make our roads
safer safer and you know their priority
is to cycle safely um but that there are
the what are called the lycra outs who
are really against in any case i think
the day has now come it's not far away
when the government are going to listen
and they're going to actually impose the
same legislation that exists for cars
and for e-scooters motorbikes
motorcycles for cyclists and um
it needs to happen it's a sensible thing
and i think we'll all benefit from it
and i think it will actually help remove
the friction that exists
between the two sets of the main groups
the motorists and the cyclists it's an
unpleasant experience
and
you know on the continent that there's a
much more friendly atmosphere here it
doesn't work very well and i think this
is a step to making us all realize we
share limited road space we need to be
collaborative we work together and try
and be safe for everybody so cyclists
have got a new highway code which they
welcome it gives them a massive priority
but also they're going to have to comply
with some legislation they're going to
have to be identifiable and i think if
they're identifiable they'll cycle
sensibly and they'll be more responsible
because they're going to be accountable
aren't we well i've got to say one thing
you'll absolutely know in the next 10
minutes well i won't make a lawyer i
welcome to the studio dave sherry um
you're described as britain's most hated
and militant cyclist
uh and you're sat there in a in a stab
proof vest and you've got a camera on
your helmet davey let's just start as we
mean to go on right you you've got ten
minutes to convince me that i'm wrong
and and you are right as a cyclist you
tell my team you have a duty of care
under the law as everyone is using the
roads together yeah yeah if you're using
the same roads as motorists then why
don't you have to pay for it like
motorists have do then because we're
down the mid and the mission
so that's the only reason you should pay
road tax what about what about the tax
to make sure the roads are are safe and
well kept why shouldn't cyclists pay for
that as well as motorists right road tax
was abolished was brought in as a visual
vehicle exercise duty yeah
basically it's based on co2 emissions
cycles do not do that
cycles i don't think damaged too much
tarmac
um
so basically you use the roads and you
want potholes fixed so motor is supposed
to pay for that as well right yeah but
so do all shriners mobility scooters oh
come on man listen listen
right cyclists let's let's get let's get
straight to it right the laws for
cyclists were brought in in 1861 for
horses and carts here's what i want to
say to you and tell me i'm wrong right
so there i am in my car and nine times
out of ten and i'm not saying it's all
of them in their lycra with their beards
they go uh
up inside you onto the pavement through
a red light there must be an
acknowledgement in the cycling
fraternity that there are a number of
cyclists thousands of them out to make
motorist lives difficult you must accept
that why have you got a camera on your
helmet why are you wearing a stab proof
vest man
because i don't like the
prima donna drivers the ones who like to
use handheld devices
the ones who get a bit too close to
vulnerable road users and i understand
what you're saying about the law the
road traffic act is there for motorised
vehicles
cyclists are not motorized vehicles okay
but if you kill someone a cyclist goes
down for a maximum of two years under
the 1861 law i'm not condoning anything
like that if it's a if it's a motorist
he goes to prison for life you can take
your co2 emissions i want to ask you
something why are a majority maybe
majority is the wrong word why do so
many cyclists in my life why are they
out to cause trouble why why have you
why have you got a camera it seems that
it's gone the other way i'm all for
cyclists right if it's fair and proper
but it's not like that anymore motorists
in this country whether you like this or
not are hacked off with cyclists because
they feel like we're second-class
citizens why aren't you insured
because we're not on my wireless vehicle
it's just ridiculous i'm sorry but you
need insurance for mike ryan's vehicle
what about you someone what about
insurance today and it comes down to a
civil claim civil loss got all the
answers haven't you
you don't i i don't understand why all
right give me another one right so uh if
i'm out on a sunday packs of them right
and i have to move out five why are they
allowed to cycle in pairs why not in a
straight line circles are road users and
entitled to use as much of the lane as
they deem fit so you can use as much of
the road as you want because you're road
users but you don't pay for the upkeep
of that because you don't have co2
emissions is that
right where does it say we have to pay
for it or contribute to it
what i'm saying is in terms of if you
look at it cyclists seem to be gaining
the upper hand
is that good thing or a bad thing bad
thing for whom what for whom the rest of
the world
pedestrians are not upset about it i
don't believe horse riders
no
531 incidents i believe off the top of
my head last year with cyclists uh
hitting or bashing into pedestrians and
how many vehicles is that your answer
i'm asking do you not think that
cyclists should have a series of rules
to to to give them responsibility be
that tax or you do it's called the
highway code for cyclists do you not
think you should get points if you cause
problems on on on a cycle do you know
something
cyclists are not accountable is that it
the road traffic act can i bring in nick
nick come on these laws in 1861 for
horses and cats come on man give me a
bit here it's outdated rubbish isn't it
well
you know
dave's known for being a vigilante
cyclist and he goes around with this
camera and that's obviously his
privilege to trap motorists who are
actually breaking the law many motorists
have dash cam footage yeah and what they
have is a picture of a cyclist going on
the pavement knocking someone down going
through red lights they have nothing
more than that because they don't
they're not able to identify the cyclist
so you know dave wants it all his way he
wants to be able to identify the
motorists but not be identified himself
so that's the first thing that's wrong
the second thing is he talks about
insurance and says well there's a civil
claim many cyclists don't
don't have money so if they
seriously injure and you've said 531
were seriously injured last year it was
actually a lot more than that this is
the tip of the iceberg many aren't
actually reported because the cyclist
leaves
how is the injured party going to be
recompensed by somebody who doesn't have
insurance answer that dave said they can
answer the person who's injured with it
answer that now
let's let nick finish no answer the
question under everyone's car motoring
policy you've got a thing called
uninsured losses and this is for other
formalities that transpire on the road
would that be agreeable nick
no it wouldn't dave because i'm talking
now about when a cyclist hits a bit and
injures a pedestrian yeah and this is a
serious case that's happening more and
more frequently and cyclists are
uninsured so there's no remedy for the
cyclist that's a for the pedestrian and
that's of course um dependent upon the
cyclists being apprehended stopping at
the scene many of them don't do you
think the law is biased inside the end
of the way at the end of the day the
podesta
well the pedestrians you know he's
injured he's lying they might have a
broken leg whatever loses his job etc
etc no recompense because we haven't got
a responsible cyclist who can hold his
hands up he's got money in his pocket
and he has no insurance so there's a
huge disadvantage and that's why of
course motorists have to be insured so
it is going to happen cyclists are going
to have to be insured along with these
scooter riders and of course electric
bike riders which is something that's
going to come out it needs to happen as
far as contribution to roads are
concerned of course there are no
emissions
but there is a cost to the the taxpayer
to the public of having cycle lanes for
for allowing them to do what they do
and there's no such thing as a free
cycle there must be some level of
contribution um and it's blind to simply
say you know we don't cause any damage
to the road surface we don't harm the uh
environment so why should we contribute
well the answer is the the motorist is
having his his space surrendered to the
cyclist and that's something that he's
contributed to financially and there
must be a price for the cyclist to pay
for that completely agree with sharing
limited space it doesn't it doesn't come
free thanks nick what's your answer to
that dave sherry i agree with nick on
that in principle
but then my argument in return would be
are the horse riders
you should be a politician are the horse
riders home to use
it's not about horse riders it's about
but look here's what i'm going to say
you go out with your camera and your
stab vest you're looking for trouble
you're a vigilante you love all this
stuff i'm simply saying to you we
motorists feel like it's all stacked in
your favor we pay all the bills we take
all the rubbish we've got all the fines
we got and it's about time cyclists who
seem to increasingly dominate our damn
roads took a bit of responsibility
what's wrong with that man
car drivers over the years have had that
same mentality the shoes on the other
foot because too many cyclists were
being killed due to negligent driving
and basically this highway code changed
changed the mentality
why i'm so important to you why are you
why do you why are you so pro cycling
did you fail your driving testers i mean
no i'm a professional driver you're a
professional driver
and you've taken this and what so do you
literally feel like you have to wear a
stab proof that's so bad are my fellow
motorists is that right
sometimes motorists misbehave and so do
cyclists
no one's perfect
but it's well that's a doing it again
you should be in the conservative
government man you haven't answered a
question do you think that cyclists
should take more responsibility final
question for
road upkeep for insurance do you think
they should be regulated yes or no you
do yes yeah if it makes a road to save a
better place there we go every road user
so you agree with me
to a degree if it makes things improve
yes it would be forward and just get rid
of that camera uh thank you very much
dave sherry thank you and cheshire nick
freeman mr loophole uh next on
uncensored and this is a story that
affected everybody and will continue to
do so 87 year old thomas o'halloran was
minding his own business yesterday on
his mobility scooter when he was stabbed
and left to die in broad daylight he is
the latest victim of what feels like an
increasingly lawless britain the big
question is what are we going to do
about this it's getting
so so difficult out there we're talking
to former scotland the architect of
peter blexley next and
a wonderful guest a victim of antisocial
behavior roy muller who says and i quote
jez i've given up on the police they
can't help me we're coming back next
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored my friends
now if it feels less safe in the uk
right now that's probably because it is
more crimes are being committed fewer
crimes are being investigated and london
has seen six murders alone in the last
four days thomas o'halloran was out on
his mobility scooter just around the
corner from this studio yesterday when
he was stabbed in broad daylight the 87
year old was able to travel 75 yards on
his scooter to ask for help but died
later in hospital the grandfather was
described as a much-loved member of the
local community the police the met
police have released this image of a man
who ran away from the scene with a knife
but this senseless violence that
happened in greenfield follows a
disturbing recent pattern down the road
in brent a triple shooting has left a 21
year old man with life-changing
industries injuries rather impressed in
a murder investigation has been launched
after a man was attacked by two men
following a disturbance on a night out
in guysbar a 16 year old boy has
appeared in court charged with the
murder of 62 year old alan garbert early
this month and in birmingham a
grandfather of nine roy muller was
assaulted outside his own home by a gang
of youth while facing
years of torment now in a moment i'm
going to speak to roy and really really
looking forward to that but first i want
you to look at this door cam footage of
the attack and i just want to say it's
tough viewing have a look
[Applause]
oh
roy joins me now and i'm also joined by
former scotland detective peter blexley
um peter in a sec um but i want to start
with you roy if i can um
i wanted to do this story more than any
other since i started uncensored because
it drives me
to distraction what's going on um you
have suffered 10 months of abuse from
jobs outside your birmingham home just
put in your own words what that's done
to you psychologically emotionally just
in in terms of your entire life
it's actually put my whole my life on
hold for a while um
i sit right at the window
waiting for any more attacks and that
and
anytime i heard noises out there i'm
rushing over to see is this it again
happening
if i'm in the garden and i hear people
outside i have to rush through to the
house and just see what's going on
and it's just all the time i'm waiting
for another incident
um tell me the worst moment uh we see
the footage there which is just
appalling are you
are you scared are you resilient wha
what goes through your head on a daily
basis right well i'm quite a resilient
person uh which is why i challenge them
um but since that footage that you've
got there was another incident a couple
of days after that
and the guy come here remember me maybe
not pretty close to take your mask off
and i'll tell you and he said we're
coming back for you and uh anyhow it's
um
they tried to surround me but i was
having none of that and uh
anyway they did uh disappear shortly
afterwards after throwing a load of
abuse at me
but uh yeah it's not pleasant she's not
pleasant i bring
the neighbours don't want to get him
of course not i'll bring peter in a
minute but um
i thought the most shocking thing about
your story roy was that he said i've
written directly to the chief constable
of west midlands police uh dave thompson
asking for help and shame on you dave
thompson because you haven't written
back this is a statement from the police
if we can just put this up on the screen
we're investigating after receiving
reports of a man in his seventies being
the victim of assault and harassment in
great bar we fully understand how
distressing this is and are looking to
safeguard the man whilst progressing
inquiries to establish those responsible
peter blexley a former scotland yard
detective the 76 year old man this
really gets me so forgive me who spent
his entire life working for a living
paying tax would expect more from the
british police dave thompson chief
council of the west midlands i repeat
disgraceful what the hell is going on
peter i'm sure you remember the
expression an englishman's home is his
castle yeah absolutely well to be
attacked to be threatened
in or outside your own home must be
utterly ghastly
i'd be very interested to know when
these matters were first reported to the
police but this is not a lone case sadly
we are hearing time and time again about
people who are becoming victims of crime
and they are not receiving the resources
and the investigation from the police
that they deserve and that we should all
expect people
write stories in newspapers go on
television programs like this and say
that out there it's like the wild west
and people say to me it isn't it is and
and what people want to know you're
you're a former couple what they want to
know is where are the police i mean we
see newspaper reports about you know
they're in training for diversity or
they're having i don't know uh a weekend
away to discuss a brainstorming why are
they not protecting roy muller who's
done nothing wrong and he's an
upstanding citizen why have we got to a
point where we cannot expect our police
force to be there when we don't need
them pete i'll tell you where
unfortunately so many of our frontline
courageous men and women in uniform are
they're dealing with mental health
crises they're going from call to call
to call to call and then they're
invariably going to hospital because
they have to be with this person who's
going through some form of crisis they
are kind of pseudo social
mental health workers that's where they
are there are police officers who go
through an entire shift day after day
not dealing with crime
the other services need to step up they
need to break out of their nine to five
working mentality they need to organize
themselves get the funding they need so
that mental health services can deal
with mental health issues and then
hopefully our police will get back to
doing what are their core principles
keeping the streets safe do you think
that i didn't cry do you think we've got
to a point where the priorities have
changed because of pressure what i've
told you before on the radio i did a
program several years ago and spent
several nights out with the police and
there was one particular story that
stayed with me a bit like roy's but we
went to the same place five times and
patently the guy had mental health
issues but they were having to do that
do you excuse the police i don't excuse
the chief counsel by the way not writing
back to him do you i don't excuse any
chief constable who has not stood up and
been vocal and been there for his staff
saying we're dealing with mental health
we're not dealing with crime and
policing matters they should be banging
on the door of 10 downing street and the
homeowner there's nobody there taking it
off its hinges and saying get mental
health workers to deal with mental
health so we can tackle crime criminals
and protect the public because it's not
happening roy um my team tell me that
you have had so much of this abuse that
you are considering moving away from
your home in birmingham what does that
say about society sir
well it's sad is this that i've lived in
that house 43 years brought my children
up there
and now i'm being forced out of it by
these thugs it's not good it's not a
good sign for society
hey um what really does my head in
is and you will agree with me i know but
if roy
decided to
i'm going to say take the law in his
hands but lamp one of them right i
absolutely am saying it right he'll be
the police will be around and he'll be
in court quicker than you can say
anything but they're nowhere near where
these youths are doing it in their masks
terrorizing this aged man that's just
not right i mean mental health or not
and i'm gonna keep saying i'm gonna do
it every night until we get a response
where is dave thompson chief counsel of
the west midlands police ridiculous at
least spend some time with that you're
not in it anymore but what would you
what advice would you give to roy miller
what should he do what are his options
roy needs to go
back to his home he needs to be a beacon
for
all the people that are suffering from
crime at the moment so west midlands
police need to facilitate that they need
to investigate it they need to put in
place whatever infrastructure and to
ensure that roy can live safely in his
own heart i get that and i am not in any
way let me just let me just say this i'm
not advocating anybody taking laurentian
ever what i said was
here's a guy that if he did
you know think
nobody's helping me
the police would be there so you know
and he will say i mean roy you've told
us you have tried and tried and tried
again with the police pete you ask him
he's getting nothing back you say go
back to your house be a beacon nobody's
coming to you are they roy nobody's
giving you any help
uh well when they have tuned up it's
been half an hour after the event it
takes you five or six minutes to get
through on a 999 call
and they have to come i don't know how
far they travel but from a place called
blocks which which is miles away they've
closed down all the local police
stations
and a 999 response is not what it should
be
peter my heart sinks
we know that policing is in crisis in so
many regards with regards to mr
o'hallaghan who was murdered
i hope they catch that suspect very very
quickly daylight yes they round the
corner from here just in his mobility
scooter and that you know i mean how
long will that take how much will that k
and then probably the person who did it
will come up with some excuse and get
away with it i don't know what's going
on we're having a new broom come in to
the metropolitan police very soon yeah a
new deputy
yes
of course standards matter like
appearance shoes and haircuts but you
know what shoes and haircuts aren't
gonna fix the fundamental flaws that
exist within the met and other forces
policing must get a grip what i've
always said is it i understand that the
policemen and women don't like any of
this because they want to be there for
the roy mullers but which you understand
briefly how people like roy muller are
losing confidence and belief in the very
service that's supposed to protect us
and keep us safe absolutely i joined the
police to catch crooks and lock them up
if i had to spend day after day dealing
with people in a mental health crisis
which i'm not qualified for and is
fundamentally not my job i'd be out of
policing in a flash credit to those who
are sticking with it and what needs to
happen for those good men and women is
that these chiefs have got to stand up
take responsibility and force change
through get police officers back to
doing policing and not mental health and
social work completely agree peter
blechty thank you very much indeed roy
i'm i'm so grateful for you sharing your
story i hope you don't have to leave
your home and i hope that doing this
story tonight spreads the word and i
repeat and we'll continue to do so dave
thompson i'm not coming for you but i'm
going to keep saying it have the decency
sir to respond to somebody who pays your
wages and needs your help right next on
uncensored inflation hits 10 this for
the first time in 40 years and food
prices are surging the big question how
are we going to beat punishing prices at
the tools we're coming right back don't
go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
uh welcome back to uncensored my friends
so apparently sad news it's the
beginning of the end removal fans are at
10 downing street boris is getting the
exit done he's taking back control of
carrie's golden wallpaper and fittingly
in a financial emergency today's report
suggests that the pm will serve the
remainder of his premiership at the
chequers mansion in buckinghamshire a
source says he wants to keep calm and
carry on doing absolutely nothing of
course that's all speculation the
removal vans may well simply be packing
for his next holiday or perhaps they've
just been to the cash machine in mayfair
before doing the weekly shop because
based on today's inflation figures
that's where we're heading my friends
rocketing food prices have pushed
inflation above 10
for the first time since 1982.
prices i have to be honest are now
higher than keith richards on new year's
eve and this is what it means for
shoppers chills at the tills
consoling in the isles it's murder on
the tescos express now we've done a
survey of the uk's biggest supermarkets
and found that a year ago look at this
this is a medium white loaf of bread
this is very good it comes from the kyle
supermarket which by the way is actually
quite slow because we can't afford the
electricity anyway it was one pound and
five now oh it's there now it's one
pound 20 which is an increase of 15 and
it goes on hopefully a bit quicker a tin
of beans right a fixture and everybody's
cupboard was 85 p
very cool it's not here yet see come on
wind it up there it is see now one pound
21 that's a massive 42 percent increase
they'll have gone up another ten percent
by the time these graphics are finished
i should imagine six eggs different
colors probably one smashed uh they used
to be uh 172 moving quickly and here
they are unfertilized but now they've
gone up 15 nearly 2 quid at 197
moving back pack of bacon it's going
well isn't it two pounds and threatens
that's what my old girl used to say and
over here in about a minute come on then
why oh there's the bacon uh we see it's
now two pounds 68 that is up 32
these by the way of course are some of
the ingredients for the once humble full
english breakfast an ordinary morning
staple for thousands of working people
but at this rate they'll probably only
be serving you at the dorchester and
checkers in a moment our experts will
have their say on what the hell we're
going to do about it but first and this
is important we got out on the streets
because we wanted to know what you
thought have a look at this
we know children with a cost of living
who they don't they evidently come to
school having not been fed but they
don't want to say it they don't want to
mention it at all the cost of living is
going on by inflation oh god inflation
is like can i swear i can't swear right
okay cool because they're gonna go so
so high so quickly but at the moment
it's mostly uh like travel and stuff is
like really bad um but also
i'm just about to move into a house so
i'm like really concerned about what my
bill is going to kind of start out as
joining me now is our financial expert
gemma godfrey the former founder and
managing director of the 99p store
hussein lulani i'm gemma welcome hussain
welcome um
we've been talking about this for two
weeks now inflation the highest for 40
years at 10
and just an attempt by us to explain how
staple food staple food
is almost for many people impossible and
i know we say every night but we have to
say everything what are people supposed
to do jim and also well the biggest
problem with this is that we talk about
staple food staple food is a bigger
percentage of people's weekly budget and
when they're the worst off so it means
that for the worst off they're actually
not seeing 10 inflation but it could be
about double so people are really
struggling and they're spending more on
credit cards but in terms of what they
could do obviously it's a very very
tough time and honestly many families
are really struggling um but there's for
example there's you know help for
households so there's feed your family
for a fiver at sainsbury's one pound
children's meal at asda there's um you
get free children's meals um in the cafe
of morrison so that's really good a lot
of supermarkets are trying to do what
they can but one of the most i think
savvy things people can do is also um
change the time in which they shop so
yes because um you know yellow sticker
sticker items you know they a lot of the
supermarkets start to discount their
food and they do it at certain times of
the day well that's good because there's
so much food that's wasted right
absolutely and not only that but there
was a family it was again reported
across the press that they got 85 pounds
worth of food for 14 pounds a few years
ago and so it means that again the three
times to watch out for are either
they'll um put those yellow sticker
items for one's approaching best before
dates overnight to go first thing in the
morning or it'll happen just after the
lunchtime rush or an hour just before
closing and the key thing there is to
try and pick freezable food because it
is approaching its best before day but
if you can freeze it it'll last for
longer amazing as ever hussein um the
99p store was the business you set up
you sold it to poundland in 2015. i i
wouldn't i think be unfair to say that
seven or eight years ago people would go
poundland many people right the reality
is that these stores now are now
providing staple things for people
because of what's going on how bad is it
out there it's bad and we saw this we
saw inflation creeping up when we sold
our stores but what's happened in the
last six months is unprecedented
you know poundland stopped selling
products for a pound five or six years
ago after they acquired us it's really
pound plus you you only find a handful
of products for a pound in a pound stool
and you know in food inflation is one
one key problem but you can't ignore
energy costs going up well i've actually
got some breaking news which is really
interesting and it caused you to look at
me weirdly off gem director christine
farnish has quit tonight over the energy
price cap what does that mean because
she can't handle well the biggest the
biggest um uh pushback people have had
is what's an energy price cap when it's
not capping anything yeah and also
there's a target it's not a cap exactly
and also the problem is is that they
used to adjust it if it was going to be
adjusted at all once every six months
and they recently came out and said
they're going to be adjusting it every
three months obviously to allow it to
fall but really it's to allow it to rise
much more quickly as well so she's not
the big criticism was that the off gem
didn't do enough to protect consumers
and during that time obviously energy
companies have benefited
unbelievable um hussein um
how do we get out of this for people
watching who watch and go yes but we
know about that inflation up
food prices through the roof petrol
diesel electricity gas so what we've got
to do is we've got to focus on the most
vulnerable in society quite right
average you know the average household
income is about 30 000 pounds and you
know they will weather the storm they'll
have to cut back the middle class will
maybe not go out for the fancy meal not
get a new sofa a new tv but the most
vulnerable in society the poorest in
society those on benefits those on
universal credit because as you so
rightly said food and energy makes up a
bigger proportion of the small amount of
money they get and that's what we've got
to focus on so one great idea i've heard
recently is to have social pricing for
energy for those most vulnerable in our
society
having a special tariff just can i can i
do something that i do all the time and
i do it without apologizing i absolutely
know what you're saying about people on
benefits and people on universal credit
but i talk about jams every single night
in the show they're just about managing
because people who are not on benefits
and do not get universal credit and both
the couple's partners work and they pay
all their bills and they have jack left
and those people could do with help as
well because they are right on the line
but you're right why can't we right on
the line and the danger is that they
will fall over
and all of a sudden they won't be able
to keep up with their mortgage payments
and then you know we've got issues of
homelessness more people losing their
homes um interest rates are going up
that's another
factor that's now affecting every
household budget and you know the scary
thing is this this is a cascade because
the family stops going out for meals so
the shop the restaurant now suffers the
workers in the restaurants get laid off
more unemployment and you know people
stop going out shopping to buy luxury
items buying a new suit or a pair of
trousers again retailer stuff where the
employees suffer the whole logistics
chain did nobody you're a businessman
i'm not right but both of you
cascades a great word it's like the dam
has been broken and everything is
falling about our our feet did nobody
see this coming i mean people are going
boris but i mean i've heard about
ukraine i've heard about the pandemic
i've heard but
the monumental scale of how people's
lives are going to be impacted as has i
think shocked everybody the government
as well or not well the thing is is that
as soon as you had the russia ukraine
conflict that was inevitably on day one
that was going to affect the oil price
if that's going to affect the oil price
it's going to affect energy bills and
it's going to affect everything what's
really interesting is there is a bit of
light at the end of the tunnel in terms
of the wholesale price of flour of wheat
and also of oil has actually come down
recently but enough but it will take
about six months for that for that to
filter through to supermarkets and in
those six months if we're having such a
damaging effect on consumers and not
going out and buying as much businesses
then suffer more jobs are lost and by
the time that actually filters through
the economy has already been damaged and
then we're talking about winter as well
and yeah exacerbating every problem it's
terrifying for so many families you know
i used to be on on the board of age uk
and we look after the elders in our in
our society they're terrified you know
they can't they can barely afford
electricity and heat anyway and they've
got winter approaching and right now
there's there's no hell what is a
hundred pounds energy credit gonna do
for them you know the advice they're
getting now is get some more blankets
that's why that's why i got so upset
about that story with roy muller who's
worked all of his life and paid his
taxes in his house in birmingham being
you know just dealing with jobs you know
threatening him each and every day and
wants to leave a house he's been in for
44 years can we both of you is there
anything you can say to give people hope
because i don't want to sit here and say
you know sugar coated it's not great but
you've been really constructive over the
last two weeks what can you say jim well
i think one of the big stark stats i saw
recently is the fact that people are now
using their credit cards to buy
essential goods it's not for luxury
items anymore it's for essential goods
which means that people are more likely
to be falling into debt and obviously
that gets more and more expensive so
things like becoming a little bit more
savvy about where you shop be aware of
convenience stores try to get larger
stores
and look at loyalty programs also try
and compare them you know all these
little small things look it's tiny
things but at times like this it really
is about surviving not thriving it's
about trying to survive this period um
to be able to get through the winter
saying um just sum it up for me what
would you say to people watching this
tonight i would say watch your pennies
you know when when i had my stores you
know it was a 99 peace store and we said
watch that you know we give you a penny
change but today more than ever that
penny change really does count and
you're right you know trade down go to
different stores shop around buy frozen
products because they last longer less
likely to spoil and you know just
tighten your belts and you know let's
just hold tight and try to weather the
storm but it won't last forever you know
and that's the message and it won't you
know it won't last forever eventually we
will get out of this war with you you
know russia will withdraw from ukraine
and that will get the balance right uh
really good thank you love it gemma
godfrey uh hussein lelani foreign 99p
store thank you for joining us right
next and uncensored tonight's jesus
journals our former labour minister
stephen pam and talk tv presenter david
bull we're coming back in three don't go
anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back my friends to uncensored
it's time for jesus journalism joining
me this evening is ex-labor minister
stephen poundland and talk tv legend dr
david bull how are we very well
you're still alive and i just walked
around the corner there you go fantastic
gentlemen so much to talk about i'm
gentlemen
yes let's start with liz trust the uh
the leader the leading candidate to be
the next prime minister she says and i
quote um well look at this britain's are
lazy watch this for a minute
there's a fundamental issue of british
working culture it's about wanting the
easy answers that's my reflection on the
election and what's going for it and the
referendum it's like
you say it's all europe that's causing
this problem
it's mindfulness yeah
what needs to happen is to me
but more the more graft
but it's it's not a popular message
um that's not a good look stephen pound
no it isn't i mean she's supposed to be
on a charm offense i think she's
forgotten the charm
i mean she's insulted nicolas sturgeon
this morning she insulted michelle
o'neal and now she's insulted the entire
british working class and it's not bad i
think she may be making the fatal
mistake that the labour party made in
choosing a leader who appeals very much
to the core membership but is not mildly
popular on the doorstep um i think she
could well win but i think to actually
say that we're a bunch of workshop
skyvers it's appalling because we
actually work the longest hours in
europe our productivity is may not be
great but the key thing here is
productivity is usually measured in
widgets and cars and things what we do
in this country what we make in this
country it's sort of the modern digital
economy the different world we make
films here we make computer games and
you can't actually calculate them in the
same way that you can widgets in
washington you can tell a politician
they just go on no no they're very well
done
at my age it's not bad no i've heard
that at least trust will win i think i
mean good luck to rishi sunak i i've
said it many times i think if whoever
did what he did to boris johnson the 180
000 people who decided next prime
minister doesn't i think 150. is this
going to make any difference no i don't
think it is i think you're right she is
talking to obviously the conservative
members 150 000 i think we think that 80
percent of the votes have now been cast
i think it's pretty clear that rishi
sooner cannot catch up at this point i
may be wrong on that but just in terms
of what she said i think it's such a
gross generalization isn't it i think
it's about people being instilled with
values by their parents i know loads of
working-class people who've done
fantastically well because of course
they actually tried really hard and
worked hard again but that whole sound
bite thing is being aimed at a hundred
and i don't know if it's 50 60 70 or 80
000 but who leaked it that's the problem
that's it well probably but i don't know
but but do you think that very briefly
do you think that the membership would
go yeah good on you liz because to me
it's a bit sound bitey i'm just
i don't think the membership will
actually appreciate that particularly i
think i think they'll be very split on
that but the point is that actually we
should celebrate british people working
hard everybody will think as long as it
applies to somebody else they agree but
the minute you actually look at yourself
and it's back at you then i have to say
i've gotta i've gotta throw this in
minneapolis public schools defending its
upcoming contract uh promoting laying
off white teachers over teachers of
color part of a new agreement starting
in the spring of 2023 can you just nail
this it's racist isn't it well it's
bloody depressing i tell you that look i
mean the thing you've seen this thing
today about the air force um when
they're saying that they would actually
recruit people from colour and women
yesterday
but this insults all those people of
color all those women all those people
who fought for the aria
what an absolute bloody insult in
minneapolis they haven't got a
particularly brilliant record have they
when it comes to race relations but also
you don't find racism with racism and
this is positive discrimination i think
it's totally wrong we we actually broke
that news if you remember yesterday
about the area absolutely and it's all
wrong i just don't understand why we've
got to this stage the point is we should
get the best the brightest people into
because but that's the point in any job
diversity is important but if it comes
at the expense of who's the best person
for the job where are we headed this is
an interesting one young brits are less
likely to pick fish and chips as their
favorite takeaway with just one in 14
under 20
who's there
oh god honestly this is why
andy yes handy oh look morgan's meals
they didn't change the name i'd have cut
ow got my finger caught in your zip
kyle's cafe what is this
look at you're going to be selling oh
yum
my dad works in a fish and chip shopping
is very proud of me right now yeah well
just you built your part up get off
there so would you like some of my fish
what that's very kind of thank you very
much indeed would you like i'm between a
cod and a hard place here
a poundland joke from steven pound 99p
at best um honestly those are as cold as
anything you need your bags not a
warming bag um
the world's changed yes but they're too
woke aren't they we started this very
quickly about the food prices and
inflation and how staple food is now
becoming too expensive and i'll finish
by asking you both
not a lot of time discuss the living
crisis this is appalling stephen for so
many people well of course it is i think
the idea of actually bringing in a
proper energy cap instead of having it
you know letting it roar up to four
thousand pounds which will kill people
in this world and it won't just kill
people in the domestic environment it'll
actually mean that they have no money to
spend they'll be therefore business will
slow down nothing will be done in the
high street this i think you know
without being alarmist we're looking
down the barrel of a gun here we've got
to do something bloody serious now and
actually david tonight i've gone direct
to christine farnish's quiz
i mean i think the whole thing is
disgraceful what on earth have they been
doing one job how well have they done it
very poorly
i spoke to you yesterday about this
people are struggling now how can you
afford 350 400 pounds a month on top of
you can't see going to debt and that
doesn't help the situation and and i
keep saying i said it earlier we should
be making it we should look at the
people that need it i really believe
that i said earlier about jams people on
the edge of benefits and universal
credit who pay all their bills and do
their best are really really struggling
it's difficult not to paint a bad
picture can we just finish with strikes
train strike tomorrow mick lynch on this
show very quickly as a labour mp he's a
disgrace mick lynch's name i wouldn't
say it's a disgrace i think he's a very
good operator but i think he's not a
very good trained operator he's totally
wrong in this particular case what you
don't would you be on a picket line no
because i'm not a member of that union
right and i think the idea that the
labour party has to automatically leave
a bit of virtue signaling by rocking up
to every single picket line everywhere
not if you want to be on the front bench
understand you can't say that yesterday
i was on the front bench under jeremy
corbyn and i never went on good lord
that's something to be unproud of also
let's be clear here this is an industry
that was paid a lot of money by
government to keep it afloat this is an
industry where they had furlough let's
look at the one million small businesses
that got nothing electric
on 14 grand
it's not 59. a lot of train drivers will
then go into the higher tax bracket
because of fiscal debt because they get
this pay right you know they're going to
be fill your face full of my chips
you've been amazed very greasy
david bullon the legend that is steven
poundland as ever brilliant
that yes thank you sir no no i'm paying
the penny back that's it for me by the
way if i don't do this i'll be i'll be
in big trouble good luck to all the
students expecting their a-level results
tomorrow morning 8 am i'm a nervous man
because my daughter alice is waiting
good luck out i will be discussing the
show tomorrow yeah good luck alex just
remember whatever you're doing tonight
piers makes me say every single damn
night keep it make it make sure it's
uncensored have a great wednesday we'll
see you soon
[Music]
biggest issue in britain right now
undoubtedly is cost of living it is
energy and all that goes with that
inflation look you know i don't want the
government to do very much step back
from most of our lives but you know
there's a point when you say actually
these guys are getting a grip somewhere
along the line you want
to believe that the system that is meant
to be running things the chancellor the
prime minister who are going to somehow
step in and make life just a little
easier for the average person
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm nadira tudor shocking
cctv footage has been released showing
the final moments of an 87 year old man
after he was stabbed to death in west
london police have released images of a
man suspected of murdering thomas
o'halleran who was riding a mobility
scooter during yesterday's unprovoked
attack flash floods have broken out
across london after the uk spell of
extreme hot weather came to an end with
outbreaks of heavy rain it comes as
dozens of pollution warnings have been
put in place for beaches in england and
wales after untreated sewage was
discharged into the sea and a jump in
the cost of food and staples has pushed
inflation to a 40-year high it reached
10.1 percent in july and household
budgets are filling the pinch with
prices arising faster than wages that's
all for now we'll have more after the
talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you